the story of the Texas mall shooter gets
stranger and Stranger by the day this
was a Hispanic man named Mauricio Garcia
and not the name that you would expect
for an alleged white supremacist quote
unquote or the ethnicity that you would
expect
um you know when someone tells you about
those the white supremacist that
committed a mass shooting and you don't
know the person's name but maybe you're
guessing what the name might be you
would never guess Mauricio Garcia as the
name
that's what we're told and shortly after
the shooting occurred hours later we had
all kinds of alleged details of his
background his ideological views and uh
we're told again that he's a Mexican
Neo-Nazi white nationalist and this is
largely based on alleged postings of his
on a Russian social media site
so Mexican Neo-Nazi posting on a Russian
social media site here's NBC News a
social media page appearing to belong to
a gunman who killed eight people at a
Dallas area outlet mall had shared
extremist beliefs with rants against
Jews women and racial minorities posted
since September as well as posts about
struggling with mental health
Mauricio Garcia 33 maintain a profile on
the Russian social networking platform
okr you
um including posts referring to
extremists online forums such as 4chan
and content from White Nationals
including Nick Fuentes and anti-semitic
white nationalists provocateur in the
weeks before the attack Garcia posted
more than two dozen photos of Allen
Premium Outlets where an officer killed
him after the shooting Saturday and
surrounding areas including several
screenshots of Google location
information seemingly monitoring them
all at its busiest times many of his
posts referred to as mental health and
his final post he lamented what his
family might say and wrote that no
psychologist would have to be would be
able to fix him in another post he made
disturbing comments about what makes a
mass shooting important
and quote unquote and praise the person
who opened fire at a private Christian
school in Nashville Tennessee this year
killing six people including three
children the shooter along with that
also posted a um a series of
a little bit more fancy the shooter also
posts a series of links to other sites
including a YouTube account that
featured a video published a day of the
shooting in it he removed a scream mask
and said not quite what you were
expecting huh he also posted photos of a
flack vest emblazoned with patches one
of them with the initialism for
right-wing death squad a popular meme
among far-right extremist groups and
then he also had uh supposedly swastika
tattoos we're also told that he
allegedly posted some content from Tim
Poole so Tim Poole's trending all of
yesterday because he was mentioned in
some of his content and he had another
post allegedly which begins with the
words this post was inspired by Libs of
tick tock
and then and then the post goes into a
rant about Jews and how he admires
Hitler or whatever
so so here's the full picture that's
been painted for us
that we're expected to believe
a Mexican Neo-Nazi with a page on a
Russian social media site was an admirer
of Tim Poole and Nick Fuentes and Hitler
but also was a fan of the trans shooter
that shot up a Christian School
and was inspired by Libs of tick tock in
his Jew hatred
even though the woman who runs lives of
tick tock
is Jewish herself and has never posted
obviously any anti-jewish content
does that make sense all that seemed
clear to you make total sense
oh not at all well yeah exactly
I mean if you take this at face value I
don't know what to tell you
meanwhile even according to this
official narrative this guy was uh
apparently openly posting his intention
to commit to shooting posting photos
from his reconnaissance of the location
and no intelligence agency ever got wind
of it
yet another Mass shooter who's out you
know basically openly announcing hey I'm
going to commit a mass shooting
everybody here's where I'm going to do
it I'm posting pictures of it
and our intelligence agencies had no
idea uh still too busy tracking the uh
you know maybe the the people at the the
parents at PTA meetings and school board
meetings the real domestic terrorists
and then the shooting happens so
intelligence agencies had no idea about
it no matter how often he was announcing
his plans uh and then it happens and
then
immediately after that
everyone knows everything about his
entire social media profile including
his obscure profiles on random Russian
websites
the whole thing is uh is I mean call me
a conspiracy theorist I don't care I
don't
it doesn't just smell funny it reeks
have you been thinking about going back
to school to finish your degree or are
you just starting your college Journey
but you have little time to be in person
with classes Grand Canyon University's
online programs are designed to make
earning your degree easy and accessible
no matter your age or stage in life
whether you're a business busy a
professional looking to advance your
career or a stay-at-home parent juggling
family responsibilities their online
courses give you the flexibility you
need to learn on your own terms Grand
Canyon University specializes in helping
you fit your bachelor's Master's or
doctoral degree into your busy day from
scholarship to customized scheduling
your graduation team led by your own GCU
counselor provides you with the personal
support you need to succeed so why wait
if you're ready to take your education
to the next level you need Grand Canyon
University find your purpose at Grand
Canyon University visit gcu.edu that's
gcu.edu pro-life battle has finally left
to DC and it's going to the Grassroots
as one of the largest pro-life
organizations in the world no one's in a
better position than 40 Days for life to
end abortion in a post row America with
one million Volunteers in 1500 cities 40
Days for life holds peaceful vigils
outside abortion facilities because of
that they actually have a larger
presence in blue States especially
California former abortion clinic
directors say that these vigils can
cause the abortion no-show rate to go as
high as 75 percent which is disastrous
for their business and thank God for
that these law-abiding visuals have
helped close abortion facilities in San
Francisco Seattle and Chicago many other
cities as well they also are leading the
way in efforts to prevent pharmacies
from dispensing chemical abortions you
can support their work and check out
their locations podcast and free
magazine at 40 daysforlife.com the
pro-life Fight Continues it's never been
more important and for more information
on 40 Days for Life go to
40daysforlife.com okay first of all Tim
Poole
can we just say is a moderate he's uh
and I don't think he would have any
issue with me saying that I I don't know
that he would he would disagree with
that characterization he's not I've
never heard him say anything remotely
radical
um he's like he's like a nice guy
remember he got he got kind of annoyed
at me because I was being too mean to
Dylan Mulvaney if you remember
so and this is the guy who helped to
radicalize a Mexican neo-Nazi
Libs of tick tock is again a Jewish
woman who reposts content from leftists
how how would she Inspire this and the
target doesn't even make sense on the
theory that this was some kind of
right-wing Terror event he wasn't
shooting up a drag queen Story Hour or a
gay bar or something
this was an outlet mall in Dallas
and you could see shooting randomly he
gets it's it's not a targeted it wasn't
it didn't appear to be targeting any
specific sort of person he gets out of
his car and just immediately starts
shooting at whoever happens to be
walking by
so the whole thing the the version of
events that we're getting from
the media right now it doesn't make
sense to me and and meanwhile
the Covenant school shooting this
shooting happened a couple of days ago
and all of this information this alleged
information came out again within hours
really
the Covenant School shooting was well
over a month ago
still a mystery
or we're supposed to believe it's
mystery we've given we've been given no
official information about this person's
uh motive in this case there's an actual
Manifesto which we were told in the in
the in the hours in the moments
immediately following the attack we were
told by the police chief that that the
uh Manifesto does outline her
motivations and he indicated that the
fact that she was trans played a role in
motivating the crowd that's what the
police chief said and then that's the
last thoughts we heard of it really
officially
then after that we heard nothing and
then we started hearing Rumblings you
know uh unconfirmed reports from
Anonymous people saying that oh yeah the
manifesto it really doesn't say any much
at all about why she did it it's uh but
we can't release it though because it
would be a huge security problem
it would interfere with our
investigation into a dead person
if we release the manifesto
we never see the manifesto
we don't get all these social media this
thing you notice it's very interesting
uh phenomenon here where
when a when a mass killing occurs
and the person who commits The Killing
is not
you know and the narrative is not
convenient for the media have you
noticed that we that in those cases huge
coincidence
the perpetrators never have a social
media uh
footprint
now it's like these are people it's
always someone who said well apparently
they didn't post on social media at all
no Instagram no Facebook Twitter nothing
but if it's someone who the media tells
us is a white nationalist or a Neo-Nazi
then we get everything they've ever
posted including on platforms that we
didn't even know existed
such as the Covenant School shooting uh
what about Waukesha
years later
what what was the motive behind that
still supposed to be obscure
so
if you that's why
if you see the way of this Dynamic here
and it doesn't and it seems normal to
you and you're willing to take this at
face value then I I can't help you
there's nothing I can say to you
and it wouldn't surprise me I'm not
making any official prediction but it it
would not surprise me
if the uh
Manifesto were to come out
soon now like maybe even this week
maybe now the manifesto does come out
and we'll see that oh well you know
there's nothing in the manifesto at all
about trans it's a bunch of random
ramblings you can't even tell us you
can't discern anything from it
took us a month to release it over a
month we couldn't release it for over a
month what we were doing in that month
who knows
all right but here it is and you see
there's nothing there
it wouldn't surprise me if that were to
come out this week
and that'll do it for the show uh this
portion shows a move over to members
block you become a member today by using
Code wall should check out for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed